- Hi everyone.
I'm Saad Omer, I'm the director
of the Yale Institute for Global Health.
For those of you who don't know me,
I'm very delighted to welcome you
to this virtual discussion,
focused on updating folks
on the recent outbreak of monkeypox.
Obviously the phenomenon is recent,
and these sets of outbreaks
are attracting attention
in countries outside
where it has been endemic.
Monkeypox has been an issue
and has been causing outbreaks
for a while in several countries.
Unfortunately, these
things attract attention
when it spreads more widely,
especially where there
are vested media markets.
So keeping that in mind,
so this, which reminds me
that when you go to the
so-called source of the Nile
in Uganda, there's a plaque.
A plaque that says that it was discovered
by this and this British explorer,
and there's a plaque next to it that says,
"Well, actually we knew
where it was all along.
This guy showed up and introduced
it to the Western world."
So keeping that in mind in
terms of monkeypox as well,
I'm very excited to have
three distinguished guests
joining us today, all of whom are experts
in infectious diseases and
global health-related topics.
Before our questions, before we move
to questions and discussions,
I will introduce each of our panelists.
The first one is Dr. Anne
Rimoin, she's a professor,
and the Gordon-Levin Endowed Chair
in Infection Diseases and Public Health
at the UCLA Fielding
School of Public Health.
Dr. Rimoin is an internationally
recognized expert
on emerging infections, global health
and surveillance systems and vaccination.
She has been working on
monkeypox before it was cool,
at least in certain circles.
I know that it was cool for her all along.
She did her K award on that,
and has been working on
this infection for a while.
Her work has focused on the emergence
of infectious disease and populations
living at the intersection
of animal-human contact,
primarily in the Democratic
Republic of Congo, or DRC.
Then we have Nate Grubaugh.
Dr. Nate Grubaugh is
an associate professor
of Epidemiology of Microbial Diseases
at the Yale School of Public Health.
The Grubaugh lab uses
pathogen genomics and
epidemiological models to
investigate the emergence, spread,
and evolution of viruses,
such as Zika, dengue,
and SARS-CoV-2.
And he is done some very
interesting work on the genomic
epidemiology of several diseases, but,
but more recently on SARS-CoV-2.
And the frames you see behind him
are titles of the well-deserved
title pages of journals,
where his, some of his
prominent papers were published.
And, and these are sort of
well-deserved recognitions of his work.
Then we have Dr. Akiko Iwasaki,
freshly back from Japan.
She's a Sterling professor
in more than one ways,
in terms of her professional street cred.
She is very, her street
cred is very sterling
in terms of her scientific contributions,
but she's also the named
Sterling Professor of Immunology
and Molecular, Cellular &
Developmental Biology at Yale
and an investigator of the
Howard Hughes Medical Institute.
Her research focused
focuses on the mechanisms
of immune defense against viruses
at the mucosal surfaces, and
the development of mucosal
vaccine strategies.
She's the co lead investigator
of the Yale COVID-19 recovery study,
which aims to determine the
changes in immune response of
people with long COVID after vaccination,
as the director of the
newly formed Yale Center of
Infection and Immunity.
So the way we, you know, those of you
who are used to joining
our conversation series,
the format is similar.
We will have questions and
answers and I will be moderating
for, and I'll start with these questions,
and then we'll take audience
questions as we go along.
So the first question,
and you've been working on monkeypox
as I said for a long time,
and we know that the
disease has been increasing
in recent years in Africa.
Not only that it has
been around for a while,
it has been increasing.
Can you talk about the history
of the disease, or at least
the known history of the disease
and recent trends in Africa?
- Absolutely.
So Saad, thanks for organizing this.
I'm so thrilled to be here
with this incredible panel.
And so let me just tell you a little bit
about monkeypox in general.
So monkeypox, just as a kind of
an encapsulated background
about monkeypox,
monkeypox was first discovered
in non-human primates,
in a colony in the Netherlands
where they were doing polio testing.
Actually they were
testing the polio vaccine.
This was in 1958,
and that's why it's called
monkeypox, because it was
first discovered in primates.
"Monkeypox" is actually misnomer.
It's actually a more of a
"rodent pox" as we know it,
although we still are trying
to truly understand
what the host range is.
The first time that monkeypox
was discovered in humans
was in 1970, in a child in the
democratic Republic of Congo
who's nine months old.
And this was in the context
of smallpox eradication.
So they were doing,
they were investigating
any case of rash illness
that they were, that could
have, that could be similar
to smallpox, and doing
virus culture, and really,
you know, trying to get
down to exactly what it is.
That's when they discovered that monkeypox
actually could infect humans.
Monkeypox, then, they of
course were very concerned
about a pox virus that
was infecting humans.
And so they were gonna
follow it very carefully.
They started doing intensive
disease surveillance in DRC,
and they did find that there
were cases of monkeypox
that were occurring, although,
because smallpox provides
excellent protect...
Smallpox vaccine, and natural infection
provides excellent immunity
to other pox viruses,
which is really the whole idea
of smallpox vaccine anyway,
I'm sure you guys all know the
history of smallpox vaccine.
It's not smallpox, it's a
cowpox, horse pox, something.
We don't really know that, what vaccine,
that's a whole different question,
what vaccine it actually is.
But, it provides protection
against smallpox.
So, the time that we
really understood most,
the most about monkeypox,
was from 1981 until 1986.
So just after smallpox was
eradicated, they thought,
"hey, we better really
understand about the,
what this pox virus that's
circulating in humans does."
So they did intensified
disease surveillance in DRC,
to truly understand how it was spreading.
And they did this in several health zones.
So it wasn't throughout
the entire country.
It was just in very specific
places where they knew there
were cases, they found
somewhere around 338 cases,
they investigated them carefully.
And, you know, that's
really what the base,
the bulk of monkeypox epidemiology
clinical presentation,
like this work is really predicated
on this work from 1981 to 1986,
where they did intensified
disease surveillance.
They were giving what's
equivalent to like $90 a person
for any report of monkeypox.
So they were really doing
a lot of case investing.
You could imagine, 1980s, what $90,
I mean, even today, $90,
it's a lot of money.
So there was a lot of incentive.
People really knew what
to look for at that time.
So there was a lot better
disease surveillance ongoing,
and that's how they found these cases.
They did a lot of modeling as a result.
They did a lot of ecological
studies, and what they
determined at that time was
that monkeypox was, you know,
it had limited human-to-human
spread, that most cases
were spillover from animals.
They only were able to
isolate it in a single animal,
I think it was a squirrel, in 1984.
And by the way, it hasn't
ever been isolated again,
except for one other
time in the early 2000s,
in an animal in west Africa.
But what they just determined
was that this really wasn't
gonna be something that
was going to spread.
And the reason, and if you
look at these early papers,
what they say is,
something to the effect of,
and this is paraphrase.
But, because what we're going to see is
increased urbanization, we're going to see
improved healthcare, we're
going to see, you know.
This was the early 80s, right?
I mean, the early 80s, we really thought
that life was gonna be
very, very different.
There was a very rosy outlook
for what was going to be
happening in all of these places.
And in particular, in a place like DRC.
So increased urbanization,
increased travel,
more reliance on commercial
food products and egg
as opposed to bush meat.
So therefore we think that the probability
of it spilling over is going
to be less and less over time.
But of course, a place like
DRC, that's not what happened.
What happened was we had a complete
destruction of the health system.
There was prolonged civil war,
people were forced into the forests.
We saw a lot more hunting of the forest.
The forest became hunted out,
people were eating a lot more rodents.
People, you know, were malnourished.
You saw all of these comorbidities.
And so that's really, we saw, in fact,
so I, along with colleagues in 2010,
when we started our monkeypox projects,
really saw this incredible
increase in cases.
It was totally unexpected,
and really different
from what they had predicted.
So, you know, that just goes to show you,
you always have to be
updating your priors, right?
I mean, that's what we
do, in epidemiology is,
we're always thinking about,
what are our assumptions
that we're making, and
how are things changing?
So we had a change in
epidemiologic landscape.
We had a change in ecologic landscape.
We've seen population explosion over time.
We've now seen cases
occur in Nigeria as well.
And that outbreak has continued over time.
And so, you know,
really where we are today is
that most of our knowledge is
about this from the studies
that were done in the 80s.
I had a study in DRC, UC
Emirate had a study in DRC,
CDC had a study.
These were very limited scope
studies with limited funding.
So we have pieces of information,
but we really know about it
in rural hunting villages
in central Africa.
The outbreak in 2017 was
really a wake up call,
I think, to everybody,
that monkeypox, you know,
we could be seeing an ecologic change,
that the host range had changed.
You know, it wasn't recognized quickly.
I always draw the example
of West, of Ebola.
You know, you have something
kind of smoldering around,
like in Guinea, nobody recognizes it.
All of a sudden, you see it explode.
And so what we've now seen,
our cases just increase over,
you know, there was
already an outbreak ongoing
by the time they recognized it.
We've seen changes in
clinical presentation,
we've seen all these other things.
Nigeria is an economic hub.
And so as a result, we started
to see exportation of cases.
We had a number of cases
exported that we knew about,
of course, this could have been happening
for a long time, between 2018 to present.
And of course, that brings us to today,
which, now we have a global
outbreak of monkeypox.
- Yeah. So you mentioned that, you know,
who would've thought that we'd be talking
about pox viruses, et cetera.
And it is, for this conversation series,
thought you'd be interested
to know that our last guest,
which we thought was the end
of our semester of, you know,
of our conversation
series for the semester,
was Dr. Bill Foege, who
devised the strategy
to eradicate smallpox and
co-led the program, et cetera.
So to do, I wouldn't have
thought even in January
that we'd be talking about
two pox viruses back to back.
So one thing to remind
everyone that we are,
you can post your questions in
the question and answer
section, and we'd be happy to,
after a series of questions that I ask,
we'd be happy to ask these questions
on your behalf from the panel members.
So Nate, and sort of the next
question is from you and,
Anne started talking about that initially.
Do you think, has something changed
about the virus in the way it is spread?
What can virus genomics tell us
about how it is evolving and spreading?
- Okay, well, thanks
Saad for the invitation
to join this panel, I primarily joined
so I can get a front row
seat to hear from you all.
And hopefully I can have
something here to contribute.
So, you know, there's now
about, what, a thousand or so
suspected in firm cases that,
in non-endemic countries.
And, so far with the patterns and
in contact history of the cases,
it's supporting
human-to-human transmission
that Anne had mentioned that can occur.
And, but we don't really
know yet if anything
is substantially changed about the virus,
especially to the extent that maybe
that it's respiratory born.
I don't know how much of
that is actually known,
and it seems like, you know,
primarily right now
with a lot of the cases,
that associated with close contact.
So the genomics can
provide some evidence here
to support some of those,
and allow us to further dig in.
First is that most of the sequenced cases
belong to one major clade,
that is a part of this
West African strain,
which is thought to be less
virulent, and so far, I guess,
supporting that is that we haven't had
very many severe cases.
And, and I don't think
any deaths yet associated,
at least in the non-endemic countries
as a part of this, you
know, 2022 outbreak.
But some have hypothesized
that there might be
virus adaptations that
is associated with these,
this clade that may be
aiding the outbreak.
However, recently, the CDC sequenced
some other viruses that are
also still West African clade,
but there are different
lineages sort of within that
and not this main one.
So to me that suggests that
there's probably not something
special about that main clade
that is causing the outbreak.
It's, probably, it's the most common
causing human-to-human transmission
in the endemic regions, in
West and Central Africa.
But, you know, as someone
who really likes genomics
and likes to nerd out
on some of this stuff,
some of the findings have
been really interesting.
So monkeypox virus is this big DNA virus.
And it evolves pretty slowly,
at one to two mutations per year,
because it has these
proofreading mechanisms
a lot of the RNA viruses
that I study don't have.
But there's some interesting signs
of accelerated evolution
that has occurred.
So this branch leading up to
the major clade of viruses
that have been sequenced
has about 40 mutations that
accumulated over four years.
It's about 10 times more
than what we thought.
But some terrific sleuthing
by colleagues have pointed out
that a lot of these
mutational patterns actually
don't really match the normal
way that viruses mutate,
which is when you have, when
the virus is replicating,
it makes some mistakes here and there,
and they happen throughout the genome.
And some of them are advantageous,
but most of them don't
necessarily help the virus.
These mutations actually
look like patterns
that are introduced by
the host immune response.
These enzymes called
APOBECs that are known,
I think probably most known
for their control of HIV infections.
And so these mutations
that have accumulated
might actually be more
of "scars" on the virus
left by the host than true
mutations or signs of adaptation.
But to me, what it suggests, that there's
some extended period of time
to human transmission that has occurred.
And, that's what we're
seeing with these scars.
So it, to me this indicates
that there's probably
a much larger outbreak happening
in West and Central Africa
than what was realized.
And we're seeing the extent of that now
through cases popping
up in other countries.
I would really like to get
Dr. Rimoin's take on that
to see if she agrees with me,
I see her nodding, so that's helpful.
So with the genomics, there's
still a ton to unpack here.
We can use it to help understand
if transmission in different locations,
if they're connected, and to
help us to develop hypotheses,
that we can both test
with clinical studies
and with experimental studies.
- You know, that's interesting.
And one of the things is
that there's always the cost
for flying blind, and it's
in our shared interest
to have investments in high quality
epidemiologic and lab surveillance.
And the facts that these
investments were not made.
So, as an example, where was
the level of coronavirus,
seasonal coronavirus
research before the pandemic?
A parallel is flu vaccine,
and flu virus research.
We didn't invest in, and frankly,
a lot of that ways, the
variants are behaving, you know,
there's an overlap, not
exactly the same thing,
the behaving in an exaggerated fashion of
seasonal coronavirus, just as
an example, roughly stated.
So we could have learned
a lot of things from that.
Similarly, if we had had
investments in surveillance
and both epidemiological
and lab surveillance
in terms of coronaviruses, in
terms of, sorry, monkeypox,
we would have been better prepared for it
for the sake of countries
where it is endemic,
and for other countries
that are facing it now.
So the next question I have is from Akiko.
So what do you know, what do we know
about the immunology
of the monkeypox virus,
and how long smallpox vaccine protection
is expected to last?
What has happened to
our population immunity
since the smallpox vaccination campaigns
ended after eradication?
- Yeah, thank you Saad for the questions,
and for having me on this panel too.
I, like Nate, I'm sitting here
in order to try to learn
from the other experts
about what they have to say,
and I'd be happy to come
back to this APOBEC issue
if there's time later (laughs)
and no doubt about that, too.
So, yeah, getting back
to Saad, your question.
So pox viruses in general,
infections in general,
induce pretty robust and long
term immunity against disease.
So smallpox vaccine as
Anne already described
is a live virus related to the smallpox
called vaccinia virus,
that normally infects
other animals like cows.
So while the CDC website
says that the vaccination
with the vaccinia and virus
provides full immunity
to three to five years,
I believe that the data
are more consistent with the immunity
lasting for a lot longer,
even in those who were
only vaccinated once.
So historically the
vaccine has been effective
in preventing smallpox
in like, 95% of those
who are vaccinated, and
against the monkeypox
there's about 85% protection
against the disease.
In addition, because pox
viruses replicate slowly,
the vaccine can be, are proven to be
substantially able to lessen the disease
when given within a few days of exposure.
And the correlate of
protection is well understood
also for the smallpox at least,
the neutralizing antibody
titers above 1 in 32
are associated with protective immunity
against the smallpox disease.
And T-cells also contribute,
but antibodies are sufficient
to confer protection.
So the routine smallpox vaccines
among the American public
stopped in 1972, after the
disease was eradicated in the US.
In Japan where I grew up,
the public vaccination
against smallpox also ended
in 1976, and consequently,
I only received one dose of the vaccine.
But in the study published in 2008,
the researchers found that in 97%
of the participants that
they've investigated,
there is no decrease
vaccinia-specific antibody titers
that would've noted with age
over a follow up period of 88 years.
That's pretty remarkable.
Another study found that T-cell responses
after vaccinia vaccine last for 30 years.
So we can expect significant level
protection against disease,
in those who have been
previously vaccinated
with the vaccinia vaccine,
and hopefully the same kind of protection
would apply for monkeypox.
- So a related sort of question,
and actually I'll take a
question from the audience
because it's related, sort of,
kind of earlier than we planned to.
So this question is from Edward Arenberg.
Is there any heterologous,
and this is to you, Akiko,
do you think, and are you aware of,
any heterologous protection
against monkeypox virus,
from molluscum contagiosum virus?
You know, any thoughts on that, look,
if early in the outbreak,
We should be asking
broad questions.
- [Anne] Yeah, sort of.
- Because, and then sort of exploring
these kinds of hypotheses.
Obviously this is not "purely"
early in the outbreak,
but in this phase of the outbreak.
- Yeah, so I have no data about that,
but really depends on how
related these viruses are.
And, Anne, if you have any
insights, please jump in.
- Well, I think that,
so I think that this is a
really interesting question.
I don't know about molluscum contagiosum.
I don't know.
And it's a good question.
I literally was just
writing it down saying, oh,
I think that's an interesting question.
Mark Slifka might be a good
person to ask about this
because he's the person who, in 2008,
I believe it was his paper
you were talking about,
he did some of that early work.
But you know, what it made me think about,
and these are just thoughts
that I'm having, you know,
and this is all part of the
scientific process, right?
This is why it's so
great that you guys are
getting all of us
together to start talking
about these things, 'cause
this is how science is done,
and these kind of questions come up.
So when you were talking
about this and thinking,
okay, well, you know,
T-cell responses last
for about 30 years, we have
long term protection, you know,
I had a paper in PNAS in
2010 where I demonstrated
this long term rise in, or this,
this extensive rise in cases
of monkeypox since the 1980s,
and really correlated it with
the cessation of vaccination.
And we really had almost
no cases in individuals
who had been vaccinated at that point.
But what it makes me
think about in general is,
what is the threshold at which
we really start to see
this, and will we need,
and I'm just, these are just questions
that come into my head.
You know, if we think that there's like
a certain threshold of immunity
that we need to maintain
to be able to avoid this,
I mean, of course what you really wanna do
is you wanna be able to do that in places
where monkeypox is endemic right now.
Because it's always better
to control it at the source.
And this goes back to what Saad was saying
at the very beginning, which is, you know,
we pay the price every single time
that we don't invest in
disease surveillance,
lab surveillance, and this
kind of infrastructure.
And as my late father-in-law
always used to say,
it's much easier to stay out of trouble
than it is to have to get out of trouble.
And I really think that that's, you know,
it just couldn't be more
true than in public health.
I mean, that's really the point.
But I just start to wonder,
well, what is that threshold?
And maybe we'll have to
reach that threshold again,
either by natural, or preferably
vaccine induced immunity,
by re-vaccinating
certain groups to be able
to really achieve that threshold again.
In particular, if we
start to see this virus
establish itself in human, as
something that is spreading
even at a low level amongst humans,
or my big concern is
if we see a spill back
or reverse humanosis.
You know, then we're really
gonna have to consider
what does it take to be able
to keep pox viruses at bay?
And this then goes back to
what Nathan was talking about,
which is, what do we think
about these genetic changes
and what does this mean?
You know, pox viruses are stable viruses.
We don't see a lot of, we
really don't see the kind of
potential for adaptation
and fitness that we do,
for example, the coronavirus.
That said, we do see changes.
Do we know what they mean?
What will they mean?
We, you know, these are things
we need to get in front of,
as opposed to chasing behind them.
- Yeah, no, so, I have, I also have,
I was born outside the US.
I have a smallpox scar,
because, you know, in the,
a lot of parts of the world, they,
that vaccination was stopped a bit later.
But we should remember, look,
these countries where even,
you know, vaccination was stopped later,
have really, really young populations.
And so according to some estimates,
even if under the best case scenario,
the population immunity
provided by a smallpox vaccine
is around a quarter of the population.
Because of the, just the
population pyramid and even,
and the fact that with smallpox only,
or not only, 85% protection is high.
So even if that kind of a scenario.
So we should keep in mind, it's
not just the immunity part,
but also the demography in
some of those countries.
So coming back to Nate, what convinced,
what can we do...
Actually, you know what, I'll
start with you again, Anne.
What do we, how should we
respond to the monkeypox outbreak
or these sets of outbreaks, including,
what can we learn from
our African colleagues
who have been dealing this for many years?
And by the way, so we
extended an invitation
and there were some initial
interest from our colleagues
from Africa CDC, but you
know, for various reasons,
logistical reasons, they
couldn't join us for this panel.
But, but what can be learned
from the previous experience
in terms of addressing this
infection in these outbreaks
and apply that to this
series of outbreaks.
So I use the term outbreak
and outbreaks interchangeably.
I do think it's a set of
outbreaks that are happening,
that may have overlapping
factors that, you know,
that has made this moment
where this is happening.
But I think we may find out
that these are independent,
but concurrent outbreaks.
- Well, I think that what
you're saying is right.
I mean, we're seeing a
series of global outbreaks
and I think this goes back to, you know,
that we're clearly seeing
rises in cases in Africa,
in the traditionally endemic zone.
And it's likely seeded
outbreaks that we just
haven't been paying attention to.
And in particular, because
the west African plague
tends to have a more mild
presentation, all things
being relative, and could be
mistaken for other things.
And I think that it's one
of these things, if you're,
you know, staring into the dark,
you might not see anything,
you gotta turn the light,
shine a flashlight,
you're gonna catch something.
But if you turn all the lights on,
you're gonna see a lot more.
And I really think that this
is about situational awareness.
We, I believe that some of these cases
that we've seen in the
US are actually related,
more closely related
genetically to the outbreak in,
or the case in Texas, right?
So that suggests that there have
probably been multiple introductions.
And now that we're looking for
it, we're actually seeing it.
And this could have been
something that's been spreading
for a while, even at a very low level,
but then finally reached a network
where it could propagate very quickly.
And now we're seeing all these cases.
So, your question I think
really is, "so what now?"
What do we do now, how,
here we are, what do we do?
And I think that there are a
number of things we need to do.
I mean, first of all, we
need to be able to have
this kind of situational awareness.
So what do you need?
You need good syndromic surveillance,
you need good clinical pictures,
and information so that
clinicians can actually make
these diagnoses so that
people can identify themselves
at particular risk.
You need good risk
communication so that everybody
understands what the risks
are, what, how this is all
potentially going to impact them.
Of course, beyond the clinical part,
you need diagnostic capacity.
And, right now we're very hampered
by this diagnostic capacity.
You know, I just saw a note
that there are several cases,
I think 10 cases of
orthopox positive, you know,
orthopox positive cases
in New York right now.
So now they're gonna have to send them on
for confirmation for monkeypox.
And so this is a process,
you know, listen.
At least we have orthopox
assays that are out there.
And so we don't, you know,
that in and of itself,
I think is gonna be relevant and then
you can send it on for further,
but we really are gonna have to expand
our diagnostic capacity at a local level,
at a national level, we're going to have
to make this something
that's very accessible
if we really wanna be
able to capture the cases.
And, this is just standard public health.
You're gonna need, ideally
you'd wanna have things
like lateral flow assays and rapid
or point of care diagnostics,
but even, you know,
in the interim, really
rapidly scaling this up
will be important, you know,
syndromic surveillance,
communication, to everybody.
And then we have to
have a really clear plan
about prioritizing
vaccines and therapeutics,
and who's gonna need them,
how they work for people,
what the plan is going to be to do this.
And that really means that we need to,
to be scaling that up as well.
Now, at the same time,
we have to really be scaling
up all of our research.
You know, to be able to truly
understand what's going on.
We have to be able to characterize
transmission mechanisms and its potential,
we need to characterize
clinical presentation
and disease severity,
and various risk groups.
We need to know what the virus does
in immunocompromised
individuals, we need to know,
is there an asymptomatic
form of infection?
Do asymptomatic people transmit?
I mean, we've done this dance before.
We know all the things that we don't know.
And I think the most important
thing is to be humble
about what we know and what we don't know,
because what we know is really about
how this virus has been
spreading traditionally
in a very different epidemiologic
and ecological landscape.
So I think that the key is,
you know, saying, "okay,
well, here's what we know so far."
Now we need to go further so that
we truly do understand that,
so we can get in front of it
because stakes are frankly very high.
You know, if this virus
becomes, as I said before,
if it becomes established
even at a very low level
in human populations, or we see
reverse spillover, you know,
we're really gonna have to reconsider
how we view a circulating
orthopoxvirus in humans.
And do we think that this is
enough of a risk that we're
going to have to really
reconsider what vaccination means?
And that was one of the big benefits of
smallpox eradication program, right?
You eradicate a virus, you're able to
prevent the human suffering,
which is the key issue,
but then you're also able to
dedicate those resources for
manufacturer of vaccines and
distribution of vaccines to
other virus, or other
pathogens, to other issues.
And so, you know, it's an
enormous step backwards
for public health to
have to really reconsider
the utilization of smallpox
vaccine again, in public health.
So the stakes are quite high, I think.
You're muted.
- Yeah, so are you absolutely right.
And, and that brings me to Nate,
what can we do to prepare for
a local cluster if it happens,
what research questions
do you plan to address?
I know on a, in your, in an ideal world,
you would still be, we
wouldn't have had a pandemic.
We wouldn't have had a monkeypox outbreak
and you would be working
on dengue, but, you know,
we all know that this will
require a scientific response.
And so what do you
think, what should we do
with the local cluster and
what questions we should ask?
Especially what do you think,
you know, what you are planning to ask.
- Yeah, so, first I wanna start by
just reiterating some points from Anne
that I think are
incredibly important here,
is that we first need a
better handle on the extent
of local transmission,
if it's happening, right.
Like in our communities,
it's, really feels like
we're getting like the
tip of the iceberg here.
And, I'm not saying it's a COVID situation
where there's like, you know, gonna have,
hundreds of thousands of
people being in infected
in just a short amount
of time, but it's likely
a lot more than what we know.
And this absolutely needs to include
the rollout of frontline diagnostics.
So currently the testing
is still encompassed
in the CDC's Laboratory Response Network.
So this includes more than 60
labs across all 50 US states.
And most of these are
located in state facilities.
So if you were to present
to the ED or clinician
with monkeypox-like symptoms,
what they would do is
they would take a swab
of the pox or lesion, and
they would first send it to
the state labs for this broad,
you know, family-level test.
And then if it's positive there,
then the samples are sent
to the CDC for confirmation.
They do a genotyping assay
and chart, I mean if it's,
you know, the west African
strain as they have been doing,
and then they do sequencing.
And this is the similar sort
of setup that was, that we had
at the beginning of
SARS-CoV-2 in early 2020.
This system works great
for rare pathogens,
because hospitals and diagnostic labs
cannot reasonably be
expected to have tests
for every single pathogen
that is out there, right?
This is why the Laboratory
Response Network exists,
so that when we have something
strange that comes up,
we can figure out what it is,
and the CDC can respond around that.
However, given that monkeypox is here,
like we know that it's here,
there are cases that are rising,
they're rising around the country,
or in around the world.
It's my opinion that we
really need to roll out
these frontline tests,
and to be able to reduce
both the resulting times
of having tests to go from
sent to a lab and then
sent to another lab,
and also to increase testing capacity.
But maybe even more importantly,
it might make ordering these tests easier,
especially in the
circumstances when the symptoms
resemble so many other common diseases.
We're hearing of a lot of
cases in MSM communities
where these symptoms look like other STIs.
There might be just one or two pox
that are located on or near the genitals,
and if someone is not astute,
one, it could be missed.
But also just could think
it might be something else.
And we almost need to
include that right now,
in general STI testing.
And that can't necessarily
happen, I think,
in the current system that we have.
But, it's not really clear
to me what the frontline labs
would actually use, because there's an,
I don't know of any commercially
available monkeypox test
that is approved by the FDA,
that we could just put in all these labs.
That is a problem.
So my group's first goal,
just kind of how we did,
I feel like deja vu a bit.
I know this is not COVID,
but there are some things
that are related to this.
And at the beginning
of the COVID pandemic,
our initial response was like,
how do we help diagnostics
in any way possible?
So what we are doing is that
we are just working with
several different PCR tests to optimize
the different conditions,
to do comparisons,
to allow different diagnostic labs
to be able to look at results,
select what tests they wanna
do for internal validation,
until we actually have some
commercial options available.
Relatedly, we're also
working to streamline
the sequencing assays.
Essentially our goal is
to take COVIDSeq, right?
All this 11 million sequences
that have been generated
for SARS-CoV-2 sequencing,
and adapt monkeypox virus sequencing
to fit in those systems.
'Cause we know labs know how to do it,
there's a lot of capacity that's built up
and we need to build to validate that.
So we can have, along
with the diagnostics,
we can have the sequencing,
'cause we know how important
the sequencing is now, I think.
And then finally, if we
have a local cluster, right,
it's our plan to conduct
clinical studies to determine
first, like when and where
do you find the virus
in various parts of the body,
different tissues, you know,
sample types and everything.
And both, this could help
improve diagnostics, right?
If we could, if for example,
if there's asymptomatic
transmission that is happening,
if the primary form of being able to test
for monkeypox virus is via
a lesion or pox on the skin,
and if you don't have one,
how do we test for it, right?
If we can detect this in
oral fluids or saliva,
and if that could be a great
test, that would be fantastic.
We would like to be able to
know that so we could roll
something like that out.
And also I think that this would help
shed light on transmission.
If we don't necessarily
know how it's happening,
if there are cases where
transmission is happening,
where it's not very
intimate, close, you know,
skin to skin contact, right,
we need to be able to use that,
so we can implement the
public health practices
that we know that can
then stop transmission.
- Yeah.
So the only way I know
of controlling an outbreak
is to get ahead of it,
and we are still following
this, this series of outbreaks.
As long as you're behind an outbreak,
you have little chance of controlling it.
But again, just to caution
everyone that this is now,
we are not looking at the start
of another COVID-19 pandemic,
but things can be significantly impactful
even without getting to that level.
I hope that doesn't
become our only benchmark
of paying attention to
these kinds of diseases.
Akiko, you know, obviously
like any disaster movie
included in an outbreak,
vaccines are the heroes.
And the narrative arc ends
that with an effective vaccine.
We know in real life,
the story is a little
bit more complicated.
What do you think about
the pipeline for monkeypox,
the vaccine pipeline for monkeypox,
and any thoughts on that?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So I'm glad that the
immunology is the hero (laughs)
in most of these situations.
- Well, I would say more
broadly vaccinology,
as a vaccinologist, I think, you know,
immunology is part of that
family of disciplines.
- Absolutely.
So yeah, the good news is
that there are vaccines
that are effective, as
I already discussed,
against the monkeypox, and there is one
that is currently FDA
approved called JYNNEOS.
it's also known as in Imvanex,
which is a replication-defective vaccine
that's given subcutaneously.
And it's a live vaccine,
produced from the strain
called "modified vaccinia Ankara."
And it's an, like I said,
it's an attenuated and
non-replicating virus,
vaccine, that can be given to people.
And that is already FDA approved
to prevent monkeypox disease.
But the strategic national stockpile has
other smallpox vaccines
that could also be deployed
if needed, such as the more traditional
vaccinia virus vaccine called ACAM2000.
It's also known as IMVAMUNE,
and it's a live vaccinia vaccine
that's given percutaneously.
That's sort of the, closely related to
the original vaccine
that was used in the 70s.
But this one is produced
in the laboratory setting,
and tissue culture,
purified vaccinia virus
that's been given to people for
prevention of smallpox disease,
and I think could be applicable
to monkeypox disease as well.
And there's one more vaccine
that is in the stockpile,
which is the Aventis
Pasteur Smallpox Vaccine,
which is still an investigational vaccine,
but that can be used under
emergency use authorization.
So there are these vaccines that are known
to work against smallpox, that
could be used for monkeypox.
And as I said, there's only,
already one that's FDA
approved for the monkeypox.
And then I know that other
companies like Moderna
are already working on
developing a monkeypox vaccine.
So hopefully there'll be
plenty of different vaccines
in the pipeline that can
combat the diseases if needed.
- So, having been involved
with, in the early 2000s,
in some sort of planning around a possible
smallpox bio-terrorist attack,
there was a lot of discussion
of that, you know, after 9/11.
And I had the privilege of being involved
with some vaccine policy
relations, especially safety.
One of our initial thinking
was that people like me
who have smallpox scars
could be on the front line
of the response, because
of that kind of immunity.
And here, obviously cross
protection against monkeypox,
as you alluded to, that
we have evidence of that,
but we need to do updated studies.
Do you think that could
be a part of strategies?
So people, one part of
diversity in this country
is that there are people who are older,
who have had smallpox
vaccine, and people who are
relatively younger,
because they're immigrants,
have received a smallpox vaccine,
and this is true for the
rest of the country as well.
Do you think there is a value in doing
those kinds of studies of,
you know, the residual,
or ongoing cross-protection,
to make sure that we have
a sort of a more comprehensive
public health response,
where we leverage that diversity?
- Yeah, I think that is
really an important issue,
especially for those who may
be coming in close contact
with patients with the
monkeypox infection.
And even though I said that, you know,
pox viruses provide
robust, lifelong immunity,
this is just an assumption
against the monkeypox right now.
- [Saad] Yeah.
- So we do need to do much better,
sort of zero surveillance,
and if possible, T-cell assays
to see, like, how long
does the immunity last,
like against the monkeypox,
and whether we need a booster.
And of course a booster is always
a great thing to do if there's
sufficient vaccine available,
but as Anne alluded to, the primary, like,
the most urgent target population, may be
the people who are living
in the endemic area.
So, you know, again, how do we distribute
the vaccine dose in a
proper and equitable manner
to control this pandemic?
That's sort of, yeah, an
important question going forward.
- Hey, I'm gonna sort of frame a question
from Elizabeth Tuckwell who
has posed that question,
I think the intention
is to clarify something.
I know the answer to that,
but I think we should address
that question head on,
early on, which is, is there any lab
that might have enhanced monkeypox,
such as some speculated for COVID?
I think we should address that
head on so that there isn't
an information gap where a lot
of conspiracies then evolve.
Nate, I'll put you on the spot for that.
- I, so I don't think there's
any evidence for that.
I mean, and there's really
is, Anne had mentioned too,
there's not really a lot of
labs that are even working
on monkeypox for this to happen, but I,
there's nothing that concerning that,
any sort of red flags that I have seen,
that would take me down
this route, but you know.
Of course there's, and
also specifically here
with the viruses from this outbreak,
we have a recent common
ancestor from the outbreak
in Nigeria in 2017,
and then the evolutionary
patterns that we've seen
since then make sense biologically
with human-to-human transmission.
So if there was any engineering,
it wouldn't even be
clear what that would be,
that would've aided anything here.
So that, I think there would
be a very remote possibility.
- Yeah, and then the other things is
that based, just the
probability of the fact,
because there is a natural, you know,
the natural transmission
is happening for a while
in a pretty substantial endemic area.
So again, if you, if you look at
that kind of a contrafactual,
it is more likely, much more likely for it
to have come from a, quote unquote,
"natural source," at this point.
- I wanna just,
reply to that.
- [Saad] Yeah, go ahead.
Please go ahead.
- A little bit.
Because, I mean, listen,
we've all been, I mean,
if you look back at even
the papers that we wrote
back in 2010, not just me, I mean,
our colleagues at the CDC, all of us
were saying, listen, you gotta,
you've gotta be able to
control monkeypox now,
and really understand it, because,
if we see cases continue to
rise, as we predict they will,
we're eventually gonna see importations.
And that's just, I mean,
this isn't a mysterious virus
that we, you know, that we
hadn't identified before.
This is a known pathogen, that did
exactly what we predicted
it could potentially do,
which is if it happened to get itself
into an appropriate network,
an advantageous network
that it would be able to spread rapidly.
And that's what we're seeing.
Now of course we have all of
these, you know, concerns.
Okay, well, what happens
if it starts getting
into immunocompromised populations?
Could we see it mutate more?
If we see, you know, this kind of ability
to continue to spread, I mean,
we're gonna get given
this virus some runway
that it hasn't had before.
But this isn't a novel
pathogen that we've never seen
before, and it's doing exactly
what we expect it would do,
having gotten into the
networks that it's gotten into.
I mean, there's, it just,
the clinical presentation
is a little bit different
than we had been paying attention to,
but it turns out there have
been records of this in,
I mean, reports of this in Nigeria,
that just nobody had
the funds or the ability
to do the kind of research
to be able to document this
where it was already happening.
Now, we're seeing it happen,
on a much larger global scale.
And I'm sure our African
colleagues would say, "hey, well,
you know, we've been
seeing this for a while.
If you'd invested in our
networks and our ability
to control this in a
place where it is endemic,
then we'd already know about this,
and we'd already know what the risks are."
And we just haven't done that.
We've ignored that possibility.
And of course, this is a
situation where, you know,
we've come into this,
I keep likening this,
it's the same as always.
My analogy for this is like,
we've tuned into a new TV series
and we don't know what
episode we've landed on.
Was it two, was it five, is it ten?
Are we in season three?
You know, where are we,
I don't know, I mean,
but we definitely missed some
of the origin story here.
But the early origin story, we've got.
Like, we know how monkeypox,
where monkeypox came from.
We know that this was
always a possibility.
It was just low on the list of priorities,
of something to be able
to pay attention to.
And even we knew there was
this existential threat,
that this could possibly happen, I mean,
it's always like, the squeaky
wheel gets the grease,
and monkeypox was not squeaky enough
to get that kind of grease.
And now we are here, in a situation where
we've given this virus a,
you know, an opportunity
to spread, it spreads
well with close contact,
and fomites, and respiratory
droplets, at the minimum,
those are the things we know.
And we, you know, hey.
Like, what could be better
than sexual networks for that?
That just, it just makes sense, you know.
I think at the end of the day, so...
- And now, so again, actually,
I'll take the liberty to
put you on the spot, Anne.
In terms of, because
we have a lot of people
who are early stage
investigators, and students,
who attend these events.
So tell me a little bit
about your experience
with getting resources
for monkeypox and how,
and your case study, which to my mind
is a microcosm of how governments
and international entities
should invest better
in this kind of work.
Because your K Award, which
is a primary investigator,
early stage investigator
award, was on monkeypox.
So you know, would you care
to elaborate a little bit
on what you had to face?
- Sure, so, you know, I came to this
from our common ancestor,
our common advisor,
Mark Steinhoff at Hopkins.
And I went to NIH, actually.
So I was at the center at NICHD.
And I was a program officer
on a project in DRC.
And when I was there,
I recognized that there were
cases of monkeypox there.
And because I'd worked
in disease eradication
as a Peace Corps volunteer,
and then I worked in polio eradication.
I worked with Mark on
pediatric infectious diseases,
vaccine preventable diseases.
You know, I was really attuned
to this issue of vaccine
preventable diseases.
And when I met with my now
very long term collaborators
and close friends, Jean-Jacques Muyembe
and also the late Emile Okitolanda,
the Dean of the Kinshasa
School of Public Health,
director of National Lab, Muyembe.
They mentioned that there were
all these cases of monkeypox
that weren't being recorded.
And I thought that this was
really important and interesting
but at the time, you know,
there really wasn't a mechanism
to be able to send them
to get tested, and the Congo
didn't have that ability.
So we sent them to the, you
know, just using, I don't,
like we scrounged around for some funds
and were able to send them to Germany
for the pox coordinating lab that was
able to do these analyses.
And we were able, it was our first paper
that was in EID, just really demonstrating
that we were seeing
increasing cases of monkeypox.
So we were able then to
leverage that, to get a grant,
it was, you know, it was at the time,
it was a sizeable grant
to be able to look at
the increase in cases of monkeypox.
And so we set up enhanced
disease surveillance,
and some of the early sites,
I mean, it wasn't perfect.
We did the best we could,
we did some serial surveys.
And we really found this
increasing rise in cases.
Meanwhile, I got my K on monkeypox,
epidemiology of monkeypox.
And when I finished, you know,
in order to be able to continue this work,
I was gonna need more than
half a million dollars
for five years, to do this kind of work,
to be able to do the epidemiology work,
to be able to support the
infrastructure in DRC,
to be able to do that kind of
intensified disease surveillance,
to be able to do the kind
of molecular epidemiology
that needed to be done, to be able to have
that lag capacity, and I
was like, far beyond that.
And so I really wasn't gonna
be able to sustain that
as a junior investigator writing
my first RO1 afterwards on that.
And because I didn't have
all of this infrastructure
that I was plugging into,
this was really infrastructure
that I developed on my own.
You know, it just seemed
overwhelming and impossible to do.
And so, we kind of pivoted
to other things for a while.
And we'd always been working
for a low level on monkeypox,
working on the data,
publishing our results,
continue, you know, we had
little projects here and there
to be able to continue to do
active surveillance for several years.
And it was only a couple
years ago that we were able
to get funding to do real,
to be able to get back
on the ground and really
do a more robust project
on monkeypox again, just
the last couple years.
And that was because there was
an outbreak in Nigeria, right?
So all of a sudden there
was some renewed interest
that we saw this shift, this
explosion of cases there.
And so all of a sudden it was
clear that this was something
that needed to be paid
attention to at some level.
But, you know, it's really
hard to do this kind of work
in low resource settings,
and to be able to do
the kind of enhanced disease surveillance
that needs to happen.
I mean, you know, governments
can't pay for that.
The, you know, I've heard
from colleagues in Nigeria,
many quotes to them
saying, you know, "listen,
we knew that there were
a lot of cases out here.
We couldn't do anything about it."
In DRC, it's the same thing.
I mean, they don't have the resources.
What they're able to do is case counting,
but they can't look at transmission.
They can't do case investigations.
It can't do all the kind of
things that need to be done.
I mean, these, this is,
it's very expensive,
very consuming work.
And DRC has been very
consumed with a lot of other
very serious outbreaks to contend
with, including, you know,
back-to-back Ebola
outbreaks and other things
that have really, you know, I have to,
I really have to give credit
to my Congolese colleagues
who are just heroes who have
worked themselves to the bone.
I mean, you know, I see this burnout,
and how tired people are from COVID.
Well, just imagine with these
incredible people working,
with many fewer doctors,
many fewer researchers,
many fewer resources,
just doing incredible work
on the ground with limited resources,
and combating multiple outbreaks
all at the same time
with very little funding
and very little resource.
So, I mean, I think that
this just goes back to,
you pay now, or you pay later.
And you gotta pick what
price you're willing to pay
and when you're gonna pay it.
And we've often said, "oh,
well we'll pay on the back end
as opposed to paying up front."
And you know, that costs
us dearly in so many ways.
- So one last question then to,
we are sort of, before I wrap
up, and a quick question,
but there's, several people are asking
the same question in different ways
in our question and answer box, which is,
and Akiko, I'll ask you this question,
should the general public get vaccinated?
- Ah, well I don't...
- Against, again you know,
with a smallpox vaccine, presumably,
or a smallpox, an NDA vaccine
tested against monkeypox.
But generally speaking,
should the general public
think about getting vaccinated?
- Well, at this point in the pandemic,
I don't think that's quite necessary.
- Don't use the P word, Akiko!
I know that it was,
(Akiko laughs)
this is recorded.
- Oh, I'm sorry,
at this point, I'm sorry, not pandemic!
At this point of the infection
we have that's going on,
I don't think the general
public needs to be vaccinated.
Of course, we can never
underestimate the viruses, right?
There may be future variants that,
even though it's unlikely,
could be more transmissible or whatever.
And at which point we
do need to reconsider
these kinds of equations.
But I think, it's not at the
point where we have to worry
about the general spreading
of the virus everywhere,
but we do need to really keep an eye
and potentially vaccinate the people
around the sort of transmission sites,
and bring vaccination and other strategy
that make more sense to contain the spread
of the virus throughout the world.
I think that that's a better approach
than doing general vaccination.
- So a couple of things as I wrap up.
So I do believe there should be,
we should build the
button, but not press it.
I do believe that we need to
make investments and prepare,
even with large groups,
not, you know, falling,
even if you fall far short of a general,
everyone getting vaccinated program.
And if we have a large set of
high risk groups, et cetera,
even that is a substantial investment.
So we should do that absolutely now,
but also we should prepare
for a few other things.
First of all, because it
is the initial clusters
are identified in MSM communities,
we need to get ahead of
any potential stigma.
We can't, you know, just
repeat disease after disease,
where based on ethnicity
or sexual preference,
because remember a lot of
these things are identified
in certain sexual
networks, but they're not,
it's not the virus.
It's the initial identification
that is happening.
So we don't know, so I mean,
there may be certain
risk factors associated
with different kind of
contact, but we need
to address stigma, because
it's in all our interest
that we get ahead of this virus by,
through collaboration of, in cooperation
of various communities.
And it is a moral
responsibility to address it
where, you know, where it is impacting.
The other thing is we need to
get ahead of misinformation.
And we need to do that, and we need
to have a robust research agenda.
And I, we received our group received
the first IRB approval of our first study
on this series of outbreaks two days ago.
And so we're already in
the field, et cetera.
Not in the field in DRC, et cetera,
but it's a different kind of study.
But, so, we'll have to
have this robust agenda.
With that, I'll wrap
up, with only 50 minute,
50 seconds over our time, I'll wrap up.
Stay tuned for our fall season
of the conversation series
and likely to have, and we know that
with the speakers we are lining up
we'll attract a lot of interest.
So look forward to that, and just repeat,
Akiko did not mean to say "pandemic"
at this point.
- [Akiko] Sorry.
- And, but things can be highly disruptive
even before, without
being a full-on pandemic.
With that, thank you, and
thanks for joining us.
And obviously I couldn't
get to all the questions,
and they were really nice questions.
I wish I had the time.
- [Nate] Thank you.
- [Saad] My pleasure.
- [Akiko] Thank you.
- [Anne] Thank you!